if you order like a forty dollar meal
for two or something on ubereats it's up
to sixty five dollars before you even
had to tip it it's a it's a problem it
is bringing me more and more steadily to
the conclusion that we just need to be
done with tipping completely it's gotten
way out of hand everyone asks for a tip
now tipping is expanding it's becoming
much more ubiquitous than it's ever been
before everyone's asking for it but at
the same time everything's becoming more
expensive alongside it something's got
to give I think we just got to get rid
of tipping be done with it you know many
other countries cultures they don't do
the Tipping thing I think we just need
to get with the times on this one I
don't see any other solution you guys
know I'm not much of a tip